my guest today is danny brown dan do you
like music
oh i guess so
round bless the mic light cause i'm
tight
[Music]
[Music]
with me today is the legendary danny
brown uh danny i think you're familiar
with my channel usually i do 10 second
videos but
i'm honored to have somebody as
prominent as yourself come on so i think
yeah
i think if you would be doing 10
questions with you if you're cool with
that hell yeah man come on
great um let's jump right in and the
first one i have is how did you find my
channel um just youtube i think my
algorithm i watch a lot of um review
channels for just about anything not
necessarily about music i just put any
products and [ __ ] you notice i love
electronic reviews and [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying car reviews anything
watch reviews that's my favorite channel
now i like this vintage watch reviewer
it's kind of tight
so yeah i guess it's just my algorithm
your [ __ ] popped up i did i did i think
that's so cool about the 10 second [ __ ]
is that you know you watch one and then
you watch another one did you watch
another one did you watch another day
before you do it you watch [ __ ] 30 of
them you know what i'm saying
yeah that's awesome
so um question number two
uh 2021 has been a huge year for your
label cruiser brigade um by my count i
think it's six total albums
and you contributed at least a guest
first to all of those and then i just
saw today that
uh all of you guys are going to be on
the new alchemist ep coming out which is
great
so obviously you're like the star talent
in there but i'm curious to know what's
your role like off the mic like what
kind of role do you play in bruises
oh really just the curating part you
know what i'm saying i wouldn't
necessarily say i mean i'll just let i
we just gotta rule everybody just um
just make 30 songs
give me the 30 songs and then i make
album after 30 songs you know what i'm
saying then we get lizzie loopers here
did he make help he make the cover yeah
and then there we go we usually get um
black noise well okay you know
that's cool though you guys i mean it's
like a very homegrown process
here with the in-house yeah
so question number three for you uh you
sir are the common thread in three of my
favorite proxy cuts of the last decade
that would be asap rockies one train uh
mr [ __ ] exquires blast his eye
and of course really doe your own friend
yeah that's kind of cool right everybody
thought about that that's kind of crazy
and there's a new one coming out i'm
telling you this new one i don't know
this is new there's another one the
detroit versus everybody you're on too
oh yeah yeah you're just somebody the
one known as alchemist because one of
those alchemists gonna be yeah yeah
that's gonna be dope who would be your
dream lineup for another prosecutor
aside from the
bruiser brigade alchemist track we got
coming if you could do another one who's
your dream lineup
right now for me oh man
i don't know man i i i would probably
just want to rap with all the legends i
think that i you know
dizzy rascal
e40 and ghost face killer
yeah
good bunch
i love that track you did with e40 yeah
but i think that would be a dope plassy
cut yeah for sure my next question is
something that i've been thinking about
for actually a few years so
on your last album you know what i'm
saying
um there's a track called belly the
beast
and the first verse on there i
recognized and it was from a
tim westwood tv freestyle yeah it's on
the boards
push the tv and i was just curious you
know how did that song come back to you
you just been sitting on it working you
know waiting for the right beat
i really don't know man it was one of
those times where you know it's one of
those times where um
you might get stuck
writing or whatever the [ __ ] and then i
had to be and it was just i was that's
when i had a studio in my basement and i
just was you know we play around and
record and stuff and i just was going
through old raps
just saying oh raps on top of beat so
you know what i'm saying maybe something
might stick a rap that i didn't use but
i actually didn't know that i used that
on the table
oh yeah
i just did you know what i'm saying but
we was too far alone in the process so
it was just like forget it you know but
yeah that's kind of tight though that
you could be able to bring [ __ ] back
like that but i think i used it on a
song
that i didn't use for old that verse is
really from old oh okay
so i had a song that i didn't i think
the sample didn't get cleared so that's
why i was just using that verse and then
you know
hey i had to get i i must have liked it
to bring it back like five years later
or something i don't blame you because
it's got
probably one of my favorite lines from
you which is
uh your [ __ ] like a leech on my scrotum
that's
question number five we just hit the
fifth anniversary for atrocity
exhibition
congratulations that's an album that i
think a lot of fans rank as their
favorite danny brown project and i see a
lot of people rank it as one of their
favorites of all time
and i want to ask you probably the
hardest question that i could ask an
artist and that is uh among your own
albums do you have a favorite
yeah uh
it would probably be detroit's state of
mind too
really okay that's because i went to
jail and then when i had got out of jail
that was the first project i made after
getting out of jail and i remember just
being in the studio and i just had a
whole bunch of raps
and i was just trying to put him to
beats and [ __ ] and i just really it just
[ __ ] it wasn't working at the end there
was like in tears like crying like i
don't know if i can do it no more like
it might be a rap i might have lost it
and i end up just you know squeezing the
juices and i ended up making
that that's what i made that in the
weekend so
so that was just you know so that's just
me it's just personal to me i guess for
that reason i was like and then i came
back home and i still didn't believe in
it i was there like i just sucked i
remember coming back home and playing it
for my homeboys and it was like this
[ __ ] fire oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i was like oh
[ __ ] so maybe i'm back you know yeah so
you know i got my confidence back and it
was lit you know yeah look at how far
you've come since right i know that was
like 2008
you know that's wild man
question number six uh you are one of
several prominent hip-hop artists who
stream games on twitch you know like
you
snoop dogg soulja boy
and i'm curious what brought you to
twitch like what got you into streaming
um actually i just was um
i mean i remember like just for fan like
live stream was like justin tv and [ __ ]
like that you know what i'm saying yeah
and so um
but i remember telling my manager like i
just wanna you know i just you know i
want to [ __ ] with it
and then we was on tour then i was in
san francisco and he actually took me to
the twitch offices
so i was able to meet everybody hang out
and just understand what the platform's
about this is like in
this was when the tri-exhibition came
out actually okay
was it
was the tragic exhibition
might have been before oh no yeah i
think it was a trash exhibition
maybe i don't know yes i try to explain
so you know and then i just started
streaming ever since because it started
out they wanted me to on stream actually
this was early in the game like they
wanted me to do like some irl type [ __ ]
like stream just like tour bus life and
[ __ ] like that
but you know this was the way like early
in the game there's a lot of there's a
lot of they make a lot of [ __ ] that they
make now that would make it easier you
know what i'm saying didn't what it is
now you know what i'm saying so it
didn't really work out but you know ever
since then i've been you know been cool
with them and been you know been
streaming ever since when i can when i
feel like it rather
well you just you're like a lightning in
the bottom that's such a great
personality and i think that's why
people want to pull you into stuff like
that but i think twitch gives you a
little more control in terms of you know
when you stream what you want to do
right yeah exactly exactly
my next question there's a lot of talk
in hip-hop about mount rushmore's right
putting together top four rappers
but what i want to ask you is what would
be your mount rushmore of games like
video games or franchises
my rushmore games i mean because i mean
because it is what it i mean
uh
i would say you have to put mario on
there yeah obviously
um
i said you got to put a link on there
it's down there gonna be all nintendo
[ __ ] at the end of the day i
mean you can throw ken right you on that
[ __ ] street fighter character
okay you can tell um
and you can throw um cj from grand theft
auto you know what i'm saying i was just
you have to be yeah
right yeah you gotta throw you gotta you
gotta you gotta throw cj on that
[ __ ] hey yeah i think that
that about round it out i guess it's
respectable
yeah that's respect yeah i mean you
wanna throw sonic on there
you just want to be like that
what about uh i was thinking like
like games themselves or like games oh
like i mean
it seems that's what i'm saying mom
rushmore mean like the best of all time
like gracie my [ __ ] that i like they
might not be the girl you know what i'm
saying
for me
for games though for me it would be like
a i would say um persona for golden
um hotline miami
um
um goddamn let me see um
out of this world or it could be called
another world depending on that's the
old nes game
um
and uh and uh and i just have to put a
grand theft auto on there because it's
just so much of a part of my life you
know it's so yeah i put saint andreas
because that was just you know
yeah so yeah that
there we go and i feel like street
fighter and i got to play street
as street fighter i got
my next question is i just saw that you
you had your debut as a stand-up
comedian
and
according to you you didn't bomb which
i didn't buy but i didn't do like all
that you know what i'm saying you know i
i ain't gonna i ain't gonna sell it i
mean i didn't do bad at all right but
you know when you're playing a venue
that big it's kind of hard to kind of
tell but i think when you're playing the
venue that bid you know for showing you
ain't doing good you know what i'm
saying i was happy i was smiling like a
[ __ ] once it was over with i
felt so relieved that i got through it
that uh
you know i and i had a brain fart during
the middle because we were playing in
college too and i didn't know that
i couldn't be as dirty like they didn't
you know they just didn't i mean you can
cuss and [ __ ] but a lot of [ __ ] they
just you know so when he came in there
and gave me a rules like i was like damn
that's half my material
so i still went up there and i had to
wing it a little bit but yeah it was fun
man shouts out my boy hannibal yeah he
took me out man cause what happened was
i played pitchfork and i forgot a few
songs during pitchfork and i just
started just saying talking [ __ ] i don't
want necessarily i was saying jokes and
[ __ ] but when i uh um hannibal hit me up
later it was like man you need to get
your ass on stage man [ __ ] this he's
been telling me for years though you
know him and tom saber they've been
trying to make me get on stage but i
just you know i hang around so many real
comedians i would feel disrespectful by
just trying to hop up there but
i mean hannibal called my bluff he's
like [ __ ] it man we playing as college
this is perfect you just get up there
but i'm thinking it's gonna be like a
little i don't know like i don't know
some liberal arts [ __ ]
town hall meeting type [ __ ] or something
my goal is [ __ ] 4 000 kids man yeah
so it was tight well you know i think
for any aspiring comedian the only goal
is to not bomb so congratulations even
if you feel it you know first set as
long as you don't bomb i think you're in
great shape
the question i have for this though is
you know what what was that experience
like compared to rapping on stage
because obviously you're no stranger to
being on stage but totally different
environment right yeah it was way more
scarier
because you ain't got nothing to rely on
yeah and then i'm saying when your stage
is a rapper it's still music you know
you still
you know i'm saying confidence to bring
you a long way
i guess in both of them to be honest too
but
in music more so i could feel like you
can damn near not know the song and
wing it but you can't not know a joke
and wing a joke and you know what i'm
saying like you [ __ ] up a joke you
[ __ ] up the joke you know what i'm
saying ain't no going back at the
audience yeah ain't no help ain't none
of that you [ __ ] up a joke it's on you
you know what i'm saying the music you
got you got a lot of you got a lot of
crutches when it comes to you know being
a musician you know what i'm saying
you see yourself doing more
yeah i'm um just actually that's what
i've been doing i've been labbing myself
you know writing all the time
trying to get together with myself a
tight five minutes and i'm gonna start
doing wednesdays at christina's spot
christina pete from your mom's house i'm
starting going to her spot every
wednesdays you know and just you know
getting my [ __ ] tight and you know
hannibal when he got gigs and [ __ ] he
always you know i'm pulling me up you
know what i'm saying so that's kind of
dope that i've got that you know i i'm
coming in the comedy game a lot
different but i'm not the average
comedian so that's right
i still got a name a little bit too you
know what i'm saying though yeah and
then like i'm stepping on nobody's toes
uh question number nine i want to know
what you are listening to these days do
you have any favorite albums this year
that you've heard
um i like that turn style album
i like that um little sims album
[Music]
um some d tracy i like um this is some
kids from detroit called um big two foe
big two four [ __ ]
i think that's today big two four [ __ ] i
like better album of love
um
i listen to a lot of draco the ruler and
stink team
so um yeah a lot of draco stink team
yeah i would say about that much and you
know i work we work on so much bruiser
brigade stuff i'm always listening to
that [ __ ] all the time yeah you got 30.
you know what i'm saying so it's like
yeah yeah you got to go through the 30
tracks
so that's that
all right man question number 10. so
just earlier this year you turned 40.
and
i have to ask the obvious question are
we
going to get a quadruple x album yeah i
mean not quite it's called quaranta
actually okay which is um 40 in italian
yeah it's done it's in the mixing pages
right now actually being mixed
um
by i think i leave mixing the same
person who did a trotsky exhibition okay
so
yeah man it's just done i mean it's it's
it's crazy because i've made it and it's
been you know it's constantly changed
and it's time to change so this is the
point i don't listen to it no more like
i'm
you know what i'm saying i'm it's on my
hands at this point so yeah uh we'll see
what happens hey man looking forward to
it for sure
danny thanks so much for coming on and
doing this i really appreciate the time
hell yeah man thanks for having me man
yeah i'll catch you around all right
thanks
[Music]
you